right john heather you know we've been
talking about it all morning pandemic
staffing shortages they're all around us
and that does include first responders
so an ambulance company in henderson's
trying to turn that around they're
offering incentives to get new workers
or hector mejia live in the southeast
valley with more on this job fair
they're doing today hey hector
hey there nate good morning to you and
this job fair comes at a critical time
when we're all trying to crawl out of
the pandemic we had those reports of the
nevada hospitals reaching capacity near
full capacity so the ambulance companies
on the front line seeing everything that
is happening joining us live we have
glenn with community ambulance before we
talk about the job fair can you sort of
share with us what you guys are seeing
when you guys arrive at local hospitals
good morning good morning yeah so
absolutely we're with the increase in
the hospital capacity also results in an
additional offload time and our offload
time is when we arrive at the hospital
and how long we're there before our
units can go back in service typically
we average upwards of around 30 minutes
with the recent spike and recent
increase we're estimating at about 45
minutes at the hospital you were sharing
with me earlier that that usually
happens during the peak times yeah so
during peak time during flu season
during you know when we're when these
hospitals are full and a lot of it is
they're short staffed right now so
there's there's a lot that we're
combating
and so it's important for us to be able
to get in the hospital get out so we can
keep the ambulances on the road and on
that note while the ambulances are
waiting outside of the hospital that
does create let's say a domino effect it
does so we're creating this domino
effect right because we have ambulances
that are are being held behind because
we just don't have beds for those
patients right at that given moment
people are still calling 9-1-1 there's
still calls for service that are coming
in and so it's creating this long domino
effect and obviously you know people
dealing with a lot especially people on
the front lines tell us a little bit
about the impact
yes or you know across the board every
healthcare provider is feeling the
impact and it's no different for our
providers that are going out there every
day dealing with all sorts of
emergencies not necessarily knowing what
they're dealing with but continuing to
respond to that call and as we continue
to respond to those calls as we continue
to expand
we're also looking at increasing our
workforce and that's what we're doing
today perfect segway tell us about the
job fair starts in a few hours from now
in fact down here in henderson yeah so
today from 9 to 3 we're hosting a job
fair if you can't make it out today we
still want to talk to you you can go to
our website communityambulance.com
to learn more in addition to being able
to be on the ambulances we're also
gearing up for some major events that
are here
that are going to take over our city
everything from pro bowl to the nfl
draft
all areas that we're providing service
for so come join the team come join the
family we're offering up to a ten
thousand dollar bonus
for qualified paramedics all right thank
you for your time and for all you do
we'll be posting all of those in all
those details rather on our website
eight newsnow dot com reporting live
hector mejia live local now back to you
guys